how's it going bros my name is b we're
playing dreams I asked you guys last
time to make some pewdiepie related
games you can make games in this game oh
god that is loud
you got them how do you get the music in
a egg I know likes Hey
all right here we go Maykel my video all
right so I wake up I look at my
beautiful Swedish flag hallelujah and I
go to make Lawai video in here okay hey
why am I not on the floor that looks
actually sick I wish my setup looked
this good
alright time to because I only make a
reasonable thing alright whoever made
this I'll check it out later you know
your stance that's hilarious
what a great get to rate it I get
someone oh it's not supposed to be
Marzia no I'm good I'm good alright fine
[Music]
Oh God alright let's oh god there's more
tribes what's happening
I can't walk over it please no it's
Edgar oh I got damn it oh my god this is
so weird
okay I flew off the map cool I think I
jumped a little high there I would never
make that hand movement come on alright
jump I'm trying I jumped I made it I by
cheating Edgar I did it Edgar
wow this is probably the best game I
remember what is happening back to sleep
no they must have spent years on this
honestly no no to be continued I can't
wait that was ten out of ten well done
thumbs up for sure okay what else I have
realistic PewDiePie it's sculpture okay
that's it that's a it's a PewDiePie
sculpture I did it that's kind of cool
PewDiePie defends his house what are
these alright let's try this at same
song it's beautiful
this is just a fish alright hey look at
this door
robbery progress alright I've been here
I've been here not gonna lie alright
let's shoot him how do I miss they're
gonna rob my house sorry I get the
clutch no no one gets my xbox actually
you can have it I don't want it oh my
god it's so wonky dude I gotta get him
otherwise I'm screwed
got him he's fast but not fast enough
why do I have no progress
oh it's their progress got it this homie
just chillin though let's just shoot
random people instead that's more fun
come on
he went near my house I swear I swear it
wasn't me I mean it was me but me in a
video game search okay goddamn I look
cool
no he's strafing shoot him in the ass
yeah you robbed me you get shot in the
ass I'm sorry those are the rules oh god
he's gonna make it
one made it one made it 2% of my assets
all right I'm clearly too good at this I
get the gist
thumbs up huge PP haupia pie will finish
the wine
[Music]
exit reach a better guys that was it
sorry
alright the quality went downhill very
fast not gonna lie I'm joking that was
the best game I've ever played what can
I say
using Drake for my to get low I or meme
using Dre for my to getting PewDiePie's
dream okay wait what is this I will
freak you out okay sure we'll see about
that
I know it might seem stupid but hold the
controller like this okay woah okay so
this is this finger Wow okay okay oh I
get it
are we gonna bro fish told you told you
I got told did I blow your mind
I mean sure yeah you blew my mind you
blew my mind absolute mind blow oh my
god oh my god this was recorded with PD
PI's camera it counts Oh God I will go
to Pew the pain Wow the counsel of
PewDiePie judges I've never felt so
judged
[Music]
no no what was that it dead out of then
I guess I'm small P P P deep I lost his
legs okay I can still see them and I
didn't lose them for the record I got
rid of them waste of space nah not no PP
no PP I'm sorry I'm sorry what the hell
is this cringe okay
cringe mean it's a studio guys never
heard of them come on oh my god
the year is 7702 cities have taken to
the sky about the clouds of pollution in
the centre one these great cities is a
large castle that runs part of the
illegal activity for miles the ruler of
this castle is none other than the
immortal Kermit the Frog I knew he was
immortal I've always said it this is no
concern of you until he killed an
innocent bystander
yeah well your best friend while you
vowed never again to wield the sword
with hearing of whether we just demise
you forsaken that while you were charged
that castle defeat this world with
Armour challenge courage and avenge your
friend alright fair enough fair enough
I like the diamond sword so I will
accept the challenge could they made me
little uglier Jesus this is some Pixar
level animation
honestly I'll show you guys later some
actually really cool ones no offense
whoever made this but it's insane what
people can make in these games alright
this is pretty dope I like the cake
[Music]
I came the from the controller I slice
you
[Music]
[Laughter]
you not Allah God wait hold up what is
this I need to play this I need to play
this now yeah amazing brought tears to
my eyes it's insane how how they make
thee look so good so cool alright I told
you guys to write PDP didn't I
pp music the good old class I hate it's
caught for I do you think damn it I
didn't know I needed this but I did 100%
hey they made the loaf a girl into it
dreams why I really looks good whoa
there's a siren hen wine this might be
more of a game than the ones that are
actually out Oh God
whoa
hell yeah Oh oh no dude
oh god this is actually creepy Oh No
or you see oh god the camera thing is so
freaky it makes you disorienting what is
that a tree Oh God there yes Oh God my
people might get there that's pretty
cool I'll bump that up so cool you can
jump so quickly from game to game
Mordy saves pewdiepie all right let's
see it Batman's got me I can't be
bothered
all right me Monday they haven't gotten
a bit about murder baby bad no yay
how's it going bros oh jeez man take my
laser gun kill all 17 eyes easy game is
starting he's fine look he's just vibing
come on you must find and kill sir look
at that oh hey we got legs this is not
fair look all the controls look at me go
send those like oh god if scenes
all right how do I use the gun then okay
I'm shooting it just this show up
two more come on baby I did it put a pie
I did it I say baby pie yeah it looked
like I was in trouble and then why does
a gun suck all right do not disturb
spends a long time classic class well
done nut simulator I don't know what I
was expecting to be honest all right
let's play some other people one then
hey I level up guys I'm a gamer now
toughen dance of course nice nice
what is this game take seven years of
development it was worth it it was worth
it guys calm down all right so what's
forever popular then hammer panic is it
two-player what's going on that's my
she's I said to play a game that's
pretty cool
whoa this is dope
I can change camera whoa hey it's star
five yeah baby this is dope
Shrek's intro but a twist okay I'm in
because just like watching the universal
animation that's it damn it no I'm not
filming that I've shut up
hey they got Animal Crossing yes I can
finally play Animal Crossing wow it's
like the same thing what the hell
Hey look at this about beautiful ten out
of ten what the hell No good job guys
what there it is
just like I remember minecraft remember
no minecraft villagers oh my god it's
Super Mario guys hey what's your
favorite version of Super Mario - The
Dream's versions way better trust me
it's exactly the level of replicated
[Music]
goddamnit
Timmy no I'm not thumbing that up that
actually looks good done out of ten oh
my god what no I actually preferred this
Russian not gonna lie you baited me you
baited me Donna the first day
someone made majora's mask 100% accurate
that's totally cool hey is big chunga's
guys that's I think now we just need
alumni and the reddit is complete there
they are you know what I think I'm good
Joe thought our vs. deal
nice spoilers spoilers
[Music]
know that all that so good its are more
Jojo yeah hell yeah
what is this it's my chair and I can
spin it I miss you so much
chairs oh my god thanks it's amazing
that's the best one so far oh we got a
fan art that's so cool
cute hey guys it's men look oh my god
they're playing spend oh it's awesome
hey look at this it's so cool how the
hell am I gonna make that out okay it
comes here oh so cute
yeah pro bro right there this is a
checkpoint nice oh god oh god what they
disappear are you serious how hard you
want to make things
oh god this sucks oh thank you Fane what
is that no not no problem for spending
guys always friendly never mind what
there's sheep all the stories so good
why yeah
[Music]
alright does this mean I can go in water
it means I can go on water
thanks jacksepticeye wow I really loved
how you created me I almost look so good
at this how you see me
the pewdiepie waves
10 10 at a time but can you do this all
right let's see it it's on interactive
entertainment presents yes
st. amant still the last of you oh yeah
oh yeah
activate share mode activate guys the
meme lives on
I've never been on the floor away is so
emotional yeah yeah press r2 to share
nice chair trick whoa
we got combos turbo oh my god yes shield
okay oh my god this is amazing
I can this smile as well cool I can make
my chair follow follow me chair become
chair what does that mean what well on
footprints hey look it's Finn okay how
do I get back in the chair oh god I
became the chair I am the chair I am the
one the way it done don't need the gun
to get
blow a baby let my the greatest show of
all time
that's amazing hey I got a trophy but
can you do this oh I absolutely can
thank you for asking so cool yeah yeah
which one was it this one yeah hell yeah
I'm coming sweat I'm coming to the
sunset and beyond amazing well I'm done
yeah I got a thumb that up that was
incredible
all right that's so cool thank you guys
so much for all the creations I had a
lot of fun if you enjoyed this video
subscribe hit the bell notification you
know I shouldn't have to tell you
there's a March out if you're interested
and I see you guys tomorrow
Hado broke this flow again forget now oh
you think your floor gang will prove it
sit down and download pixel eggs right
now the fourth chapter is finally out or
say you have it sounds like so many in
the ceiling
download now or I'll spit on you
you